[Applaudissements]
arrête de te frotter très bizarrement
sur mon dos et en plus je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué quand il se frotte ça
lui fait d'électricité statut dans ses
cheveux
donc j'ai deux trois questions à vous
poser sio sur lui par exemple si vous
deviez le décrire c'est un homme de
coeur et c'est un sacré côté un nom chez
deux retraités ou fouet qu'elle allait
faire plaisir non mais on est jeune on
suit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'a touché une carte du bout du doigt
à quoi tu touches celle que tu veux tu
n'es pas compris c'est la première fois
qu'on fait un tour ensemble celle là on
a fait des passes et on a bien carte
hockey bien pas de correspondance gibert
chamerois ça n'existera régime benhaim
on a une carte que tu as choisie et qui
est exactement celle là que je mets de
côté qu'est ce que tu as choisie comme
carrie choisi le moine mais moines et
regarde l'autre moitié
normalement ce serait jean luc c'est
normalement mais non et ces gens là je
veux pas qu'on ait changé l'est
[Rires]
les micros quelques points il est dans
ton slip